the contribution of the sound engineer
has never been fully appreciated
especially before the advent of talking
pictures but if you really want to know
how much they add to the production of
the film next time you go to a movie
house put your hands over your ears and
just watch the picture now take your
hands away from the ears and put them
over your eyes if you like what you hear
thank the sound engineer the nominees
for outstanding achievement in sound are
Arthur piano C less fresh Holtz Michael
Minkler and Willie D Burton for altered
states Richard Portman Roger Hyman and
Jim Alexander for Coal Miner's Daughter
bill Varney Steve Maslow Greg LAN Decker
and Peter Sutton the Empire Strikes Back
JM Harding and Chris Newman for fame
Donnell Oh Mitchell Bill Nicholson David
J Kimball and less lazar wits for Raging
Bull and the winner is the winners are
Bill Barney
it takes the creative talents of a lot
of people to create a soundtrack of the
likes of the Empire Strikes Back so
Steve and Greg and Peter and I must
share these awards tonight with a long
list of people which we will have to
skip a few of course particularly
producers George Lucas and Gary Kurtz
Irvin Kershner the fabulous Ben Burtt
who creates the terrific sound of the
Empire all of the people at the Samuel
Goldwyn sound facility particularly Don
Rogers and John Boehner and Bernie and
Dave our special right and left hand man
Kevin O'Connell my dear Suzy and Lisa
who somehow tolerate the insanity of all
this don digs and the guys at the Dolby
labs and you for so honoring us tonight
thank you
the Academy for this use my purse I'm
very nervous I would like to thank
George Lucas Gary Kurtz Ben Burtt and
the entire editorial staff that worked
behind us the magic worked on the show
and thank you this is quite an honor
thank you very much